oh yeah you reviewers your five hello
and welcome to the year reviewers Movie
Awards 2015 nominations alright I know
there are a lot of new people here a lot
of new subscribers are like what is that
I explained it every year my nominations
videos I know for a long time fans are
like I know what it is just get on with
it but a lot of new faces here so I will
explain in 2011 the YouTube movie review
channel schmoes know and I we got
together and we were like let's create
like a movie award show on YouTube you
know for all of us cuz it'll be a lot of
fun
so fans have fun we have fun it's fun
it's the name of the game here
YouTube should be fun so there are a
list of categories which you'll find out
and YouTube movie reviewers they vote
and thus we have the nominees and now
it's like alright here are the nominees
now YouTube movie reviewers finally do
their final vote and then we have the
award show which Mo's know and I put on
we like to snipe the Oscars I don't have
an exact date when it's gonna go up but
think of when the Oscars are you know
maybe a week or so before that that's
when we'll try to have it to you barring
technical issues that fall out of the
sky a week before the Oscars and like
last year these are gonna be half the
nominees you want to see the other half
of the nominees schmoes know they're
putting it up right now they're 18
categories and all I will do 9 you want
to see the other nines on their video
that they're doing opposite my video you
know two sides of the coin and
let's get right to the nominees and the
category is excessive what you came here
to say let's be honest for best
animation we have the lego movie
followed by How to Train Your Dragon 2
followed by big hero 6 then we have the
boxtrolls and we're finishing it off
with the tape the tale of Princess
Kaguya for Best Visual Effects we have
interstellar then we have dawn of the
Planet of the Apes and we got edge of
tomorrow then X Men Days of Future past
and we're finishing it off with
guardians of the galaxy now we have most
underrated film is the film maybe didn't
get a lot of love but maybe should have
we have the guest followed by begin
again then snowpiercer
but again we got edge of tomorrow and
finishing it off with Locke alright now
we have best villain these are the fun
categories I love like this
starting it off we have babadook in
that's right the babadook then we have
Koba from dawn of the Planet of the Apes
then we got Winter Soldier from Captain
America the Winter Soldier
we have kim jeong-hoon in the interview
and followed off by king dick of the
universe played by JK Simmons in
whiplash I don't think he was ever
called King dick of the universe in
whiplash he really should have
breakthrough actor these are the people
you didn't know who they were before
last year and now boom you know who they
are
Jaden Libra hair from Saint Vincent
Ansel Elgort from The Fault in Our Stars
lr coltrane from boyhood do we have Dan
Stevens from the guests finishing it off
with Jack O'Connell from unbroken now
the category is shocked it didn't suck
this is that movie you saw the trailer
and you're like no that might as well
come out in January and then you watch
it you're like first off we have edge of
tomorrow again then we got John wick
followed by top five so we have draft
day and we're finishing it off with the
purge anarchy for Best Supporting
Actress we have Emma Stone from Birdman
followed by Jessica Chastain from the
most violent year we have Tilda Swinton
from Snow piercer then we have Patricia
Arquette from boyhood finishing it off
with Rene Russo from Nightcrawler now we
have Best Actress that's right on my
channel I bring you the latest not
really ever except for nominations other
than that completely sausage fest for
Best Actress we have se Davis from the
babadook can we have Julianne Moore from
still Alice followed by Felicity Jones
from the theory of everything then we
have Reese Witherspoon from wild
finishing it off with Rosamond Pike from
gone girl and the last category on my
channel anyway is Best Director for Best
Director we have Alejandro Gonzalez in
your Ritu I really hope I pronounce that
correctly if not that'll be only the
fifth name today I mispronounced
probably in any gaze Birdman Richard
Linklater for boyhood David Fincher for
gone girl
Damien Chazelle for whiplash and Ava
Duvernay for selma alright guys those
are half of your nominations for the
year reviewers movie awards now if you
want to see the other half go to the
schmoes know youtube channel you they
just put up their video and they have
the other half of the nominations
including Best Picture and like last
year for Best Picture here's the thing
you can go to schmoes no Tom we'll put a
link below you yourselves you that's
right you you get to vote for Best
Picture the YouTube movie reviewers they
had their nominations they made all
their nominations it was tallied up it's
like boom there's the list of the
nominations of that list you guys get to
now pick who you think the winner should
be the one with the most votes that's
Best Picture collaborations like I said
should be fun on YouTube right so for
this half of the nominees did you like
what you saw what do you think should
have been in there that maybe wasn't
whatever
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more